welcome back everybody we're here to
tell you that the war on police is
absolutely raging right now in the past
week alone 14 officers have been shot
and two Connecticut police officers
gunned down in the line of duty this
week and they were possibly ambushed led
to the scene by a false call for help
officer Alex hamzi died at the scene he
had just celebrated his first wedding
anniversary this summer in June and
police Sergeant Dustin De Monte died at
the hospital he was a married dad of two
and his wife is expecting their third
child
joining us now is Frank Siller founder
of the tunnel to Towers foundation and
he is ready to help out in a big way
Frank is always good to have you with us
but it's always sad to have you with us
because it means that you are having to
keep doing this job of reaching out and
helping these families making that phone
call to them right away and saying I
know you're in the darkest moment of
your life but we are going to be there
for you yeah it is sad and it's
disgusting what's going on in America
and the war against our law enforcement
and police officers all over the country
it's happening all over the country
but you know the tunnel to Towers
Foundation we made a promise to our
First Responders and most certainly our
police officers that if you leave you
give your kids a kiss goodbye and you
don't come home we're going to make sure
that we take care of your families are
left behind and that's exactly what
we're going to do for uh Sergeant Dustin
Damonte his beautiful wife Laura I spoke
to Laura's mother earlier today
she said this is a nightmare and what
they're going through she could always
she couldn't speak she was crying so
much on the phone but look that's why we
have to put the pictures of these guys
up there we have to remember we have to
say their names because we can't forget
the sacrifice that's made every single
day and tunnels the towers Foundation
has made this promise and we're going to
take care of this family we're going to
make sure they have a mortgage free home
yeah you know um there's been so much
backlash in the past couple of years
against police and you look at these
folks Greg that come out to do the job
and you know it's interesting that you
say say their names because I've always
felt you want to say you need to say all
of the names people who are dying in law
enforcement people who are dying in all
different situations around this country
yeah it's I I don't mean to sound
callous but I can't keep up with the
violence you know it amazes me that
there are certain networks who would
play one video or a particle of a video
portion of a video uh police malfeasance
or something or perceived malfeasance
over and over for weeks uh but no one
maybe they'll talk about this once maybe
they won't even mention it because
there's there's no racial element to
most of this stuff or any of this stuff
uh so you don't hear about this stuff
and you said something during the break
that we were just we were going through
some of the uh most recent horrible acts
of criminality and you just kind of said
there's a sickness out there and I think
we all kind of feel like there's a
sickness out there what do you what is
that sickness well it starts in the home
you know I mean when you were a kid when
I was a kid growing up my parents said
respect yeah Elders respect affect law
enforcement and and you did it and
little things like that in school and
everywhere you get taught to say when
you see police officers say thank you
for protecting us it's those little
things that make a big difference later
on in life instead a lot of other media
and other people are saying cops are bad
there's a false narrative being out
there and when one cop does something
bad they blame every cop and you can't
do that they protect us they give us the
society that we have without them we
have no America and uh it's sad to say
that we're right on the cusp of
something bad happening in America it is
happening every day but we better take
care of it but it starts at the lowest
level meaning in the home and the
parents have to say police officers are
good just we see people cops retiring
right and left I mean you know it's very
difficult and very brave and heroic for
people who stand up today and say I want
to be a police officer because it's it's
not what it was it's also very brave and
heroic for people to stand up and say
I'm going to donate a lot of money to
fall and Law Enforcement Officers
there's such a wealthy country very
generous country but you have a lot of
these fundraisers where they're donating
millions of dollars to save
I don't know a seal of spotted owls and
that's not saying that that's not
important but I mean what you guys are
doing is so real when you think about
the impact it has the real world impact
it has talk about the generosity of the
people that your organization has worked
with well we ask everybody to go to
t2t.org eleven dollars a month and that
11 a month makes a big difference in
these families lives we've been able to
help over uh 50 law enforcement this
year alone that have died in the line of
duty protecting us
137 have given their lives police
officers this year it's it's incredible
but we can't do it without the
generosity of our viewers people should
know that 95.1 percent of every dollar
is donated to Total to tablets
Foundation is going to these families
you see where your money goes the
Demotte family's mortgage is going to
get paid off 100 what you what you
donate it's important that people see
where their money is going and what
better way than to take care of the
burden of a mortgage on these families
that just us their loved one yeah
when we were backstage we were in The
Green Room you said there have been 3
000 events that tell the towers did
Across the Nation give us a little bit
just give us a little color that and
tell tell viewers how they can be a part
not only of this but how we can help
going forward well we're proud that we
have tens of thousands of volunteers
Across America that have joined us on
our mission and our mission is simple
let us do good and what the good is to
take care of these men and women who go
out every single day to protect us
so many people have joined us 3 000
different events put on for us we're not
putting them on these are other people
putting them ons for tunnel to Towers
foundation and because of that that
we're able to raise the kind of money
you could do the math we're gonna do
over 200 mortgages this year mortgage
free homes this year some for
catastrophic diligent service members do
the math your mortgage times 200 and we
can only do because of people that have
joined us on this great Mission thank
you for doing earlier on my phone and I
have photos from Jason Rivera's funeral
who died in the line of duty at the
beginning of the year for the NYPD how
much money do you need to raise per
family well it averages out nearly uh
three hundred and thirty thousand
dollars per family that's what it
averages out over the course some or
more some less
um but you know done 11 A Time believe
it or not you bring the people together
it gets done and that's what we love a
blue collar Foundation bringing millions
of people together not just a few people
donating millions of dollars don't get
me wrong if somebody could donate I'll
take that too
your viewers uh are going to respond to
this once again t2t.org eleven dollars a
month we could uh help so many 2014
detectives Lou Ramos were assassinated
here in New York New York uh officer
Dustin Damonte was assassinated
there's no question about it so Jason
Rivera was assassinated they were
assassinated and uh we better be there
to take care of the families and that's
what we're here doing today so thanks
for having me thank you for everything
that you do and we do have
extraordinarily generous audience and I
know they're going to come through for
you and we thank you for being with us
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else